big I just saw him recently and he was
smoking he was like in public too I was
like oh he know to give a [__] I'm glad
we actually that was one of the coolest
people I've got in high with I couldn't
say it before but yeah I've gotten big
high who's the coolest person you've
gotten high with this has got to be I
mean you probably got high with
everybody at this point um somebody who
sticks out where you're like wow I
smoked with this person that's [__]
crazy dud dude to me it's it's still be
real
dude like if I'm was going to be honest
like be real is a guy yeah and he gets
he gets really high and like when I see
him it's like a reunion of like here's
the flavors I've been [__] with
here's the flavors he's been [__]
with we just rolling back to back and
you know I just his childhood goal [__]
it's also like he's a legendary weed man
too you know yes he is so like my
favorite person you know I've gotten
high with is be real straight up yeah be
real uh obviously tell me how cuz yo was
this Snoop whiz tour was this your
biggest tour you've done or one of them
at least it felt like one of the biggest
you guys I I think it was dope cuz
everyone was canceling their tours and
tour dates yeah no one wanted to mention
that the Snoop Dog Whiz Khalifa to short
mie and bernu were sold out in every
market like and in in a time where
nobody was selling out shows everybody
was everyone was cancelling and the
coolest thing about this tour for me was
I got the opening slot right it was oh
shout out to DJ Drama Drama was there
yeah drama was there he put on uh but
like it was DJ Drama than me and then
it'd be warn to short whiz
Snoop and when I first got offered the
show I was like [__] I got the opening
slot I'm about to be [__] I'm like
[__] yeah cuz those opening Slots of
those Amphitheater shows can be they
could be interesting bro I've seen it a
hundred different ways me too I've seen
it yeah but the best thing about this
show was that it was never like that
that [__] was 85% full every time I
went on there's videos the whole tour I
go on at 700 PM that bit is full rocking
nice grown mature crowd getting there
early young and grown but they were
there early because they liked the
lineup they didn't want to miss me and
yeah they didn't want to miss you they
didn't want to miss me they didn't want
to miss waren G they didn't want to miss
too short they wanted to see the whole
show and so that that tour was
lifechanging for me I thank Snoop so
much for for hand selecting that that
lineup cuz he did hand select that
lineup and I feel super grateful for
that I got a chance to bomb with some of
my you know mentors and some of my the
guys I grew up listening to and looking
up to got a chance to chill with the TL
gang you know that's family me and Snoop
got some deals coming out that that tour
that are pretty big we got cookies by
cookies coming soon under his food
umbrella so we're cookies buy cookies
yeah just snacks good snacks I like that
not infused Walmart baby yo for Snoop
like I feel like have you cuz CU When we
think of weed and Hip Hop we think I
think it's Snoop and then I think of
whiz I think of B real then I think of
you but in terms of just like the
general public everyone thinks Snoop Dog
right you've done some weed stuff with
Snoop um for whatever reason it feels
like Snoop hasn't
fully um cracked off in the space in a
way that you would expect him to I know
you guys have done stuff um but have you
have you like helped Snoop out at all in
that in in that space we launched we
launched something together that did
hella well uh the doggy bag it killed it
I mean when we dropped it and in La the
lines were down the block we dropped it
and other markets people loved it it was
a good genetic but I think the thing
with Snoop is that he's way bigger than
just focusing on a weed brand he's he's
an international [__] icon no it's
crazy this I think he's the I mean I
always tell this to people he's the most
famous rapper in the world I think he's
like one of most famous people in in the
world he's like the closest like and I
say is this may be a weird statement
he's like the closest guy to Michael
Jackson out there like he's no one like
Michael everyone knows who Snoop Dog
everybody I don't care where you Grandma
your grand who dog is you know who the
dog is so I think that the dog I think
that Snoop loves weed he's a fan of weed
he loves to smoke good weed I've gotten
high with him for years he's at multiple
Brands but I think that he's just so
much bigger than trying to focus on a
weed brand he's focused on like the food
category now with the ice cream and the
cereal like I think he's focused on just
like bigger plays that he didn't really
think he'd be able to do you know when
he was younger Snoop and I think that
like Walmart [__] like that yeah I mean
and he's not only getting in Walmart
he's opening the doors for other people
like he didn't have to open that door
for me that's why I bought him the Rolex
at the last day of the tour because I
was like you know I don't even know if
he'll ever wear this watch but like I'm
so grateful that he opened up the door
for me to help normalize my myself as a
household name and by introducing that
partner to develop create cookies and to
and to actually distribute into places
like Walmart that's big as [__] for me
and I'm grateful for that and I think
that I told him that day I said you're
the only artist I know that gives back
like this yeah you share your back yeah
you don't want nothing back you told me
BR I'm simple you could have brought me
a little bag we I said I know I could
have but like I want to give you this
from the heart cuz this is what you know
in my world like this is I've always
dreamed about being able to do something
like this and like this tour brought a
lot of happiness in my life in a really
dark time and this tour gave me
motivation to keep making music and it
showed me that around the country I'm
respected all in different markets I
never thought I would be and [__] bro
like you opening up big doors for us so
shout out to Snoop he's the only guy
that actually really shares his platform
and getes back and gives opportunities
to other artists when he ain't got to do
that [__] at all that's that's my role
model really no Snoop I I always see him
popping up on up and coming artist [__]
too like just like just randomly you'll
be like damn snoop's on like a zo AMA
remix or he's on a Scarlet record like
and it's just like oh he's he's not only
is he like you know he's just tapped in
and I feel like he's he's generous with
his energy man man that dude ain't got
do that dude's Caked Up for sure dog is
Caked Up liquidly Caked Up and like his
money is not in equity one he's Caked Up
For Real for reals he don't have to do
none of the [__] he's doing he's doing
it because he loves it and that's the
dope thing about the dog